[Music]
all right if you're traveling abroad or
at least hoping to travel you need a
passport and if you don't have one
getting one is proving to be a lengthy
process the U.S Secretary of State
reporting an unprecedented demand for
passports but as Arkansas reports don't
cancel your travel plans just yet
tiring the bandits are experiencing a
world of woes as they attempt to travel
but they're not alone we've had an
unprecedented demand for renewed travel
in 2022 the state department issued a
record 20
million passports U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blicken said in the House
Appropriations subcommittee hearing that
we're on track to break that record as
the federal government quickly tries to
fill positions it cut during the
pandemic it's covered the bottom
basically dropped out on the system the
state department continues to rebuild as
it Fields half a million applications a
week I'm not sure how much busier we can
get we're getting about 40 to 50 phone
calls a day
Aaron Neeson is the manager at the
Windmill Library which started doing
passports in 2017
teens about 80 a month appointments
always fill up but never this quickly
they're gone in like three minutes He
suggests be patient
um explore many options there's probably
about 20 places in the county you can
get an appointment a lot of them are
booked but do some leg work keep
checking websites people do cancel
appointments for these nevadans all bets
are on and the payoff is big big
[Laughter]
Cruise so remember exponent processing
times it's seven to nine weeks routine
is 10 to 13 weeks so get those
appointments in early and as soon as
possible we'll have more details on our
website newsnow.com for now from the
Louisville Library I'm Candace Charles 8
News Now
passport renewals can be done excuse me
online you send in the application a
ds82 with your picture and your expired
passport